so there's been heavy fighting in the
Sudanese Capital Khartoum just hours
after a three-day truce ended the Army
claims that it made some gains in
onderman against the paramilitary rapid
support forces meanwhile the warring
sides have been holding talks in Saudi
Arabia to agree on a new ceasefire for
the Eid holiday which happens later this
month Hibbett Morgan is in onderman near
the capital Khartoum Hibba so we know
the fighting has resumed what more can
you tell us
well we spoke to Residents in various
parts of the capital Khartoum in the
northern part of the capital the few
residents remaining behind in that part
of the city we spoke to people in the
Eastern and Southern parts of the
capital now the latest is that there is
more intense fighting between the
central Reserve police and the
paramilitary rapid support forces in the
southern part of the capital the central
Reserve police is the militarized unit
of the police department here in Sudan
and residents in the southern part say
that there's been intense fighting
between them for hours now forcing
residents indoor and they reported that
several have been injured several
civilians have been injured as a result
of the fighting in that part of the
capital we also spoke to people in the
Eastern side of hartum and they say that
there has been airstrikes launched that
they were able to hear surface-to-air
missiles and here in the city of
omdurman we were able to hear the sounds
of the fighter jets flying overhead we
know that this fighting in some parts of
onderman especially around the engineer
score a military base is belonging to
the Army which the paramilitary rapid
support forces has been trying to gain
control of for weeks now so residents in
various parts of the capital have been
warned to stay indoors to not be caught
in the crossfire between the
paramilitary rapid support forces and
the Sudanese Army but people say that
once the ceasefire has ended they're
seeing more and more intents fighting
between the two sides
Hibba you said something to us earlier
that surprised me you said some
residents fear the ceasefire more than
they fear the actual fighting talk to us
about that
while residents know that when there is
a ceasefire and it is respected by both
sides it's the military ceasefire now
when the 72-hour ceasefire was first
announced we spoke to people in the
Southern and Northern parts of the
capital to get their take on The View
and they were concerned because they say
that while it may end the sound of heavy
artillery and the sound of the fight
suggests overhead that would give the
chance for the paramilitary rapid
support forces to expand into civilian
neighborhoods and force more residents
out of their homes and over the past
three days there's been a lot of reports
from civilians especially in the
northern part of the capital of rsf uh
Fighters breaking into their homes two
civilians were killed in the northern
part of the capital as a result and
people in the eastern part also say that
they're seeing an increase in the number
of presence of rsf Fighters so that's
something that people have been
concerned about this is also the issue
of sexual violence we spoke to rights
groups uh over the past three days and
they say that they've noticed an uptick
in the number of women and Reporting
sexual violence and say that that's not
the complete number or the full figure
and they say that the figure of victims
of sexual violence is likely much higher
but because of the stigma it's not being
reported so civilians say that they are
concerned that if there is another
ceasefire it would give the paramilitary
rapid support forces more chances to
expand into civilian neighborhoods and
commit more atrocities on civilians even
if there's no direct confrontation
between the rapid support forces and the
Army on the military side hibber Morgan
reporting from umdorman near Khartoum
thank you very much